rebecca give me your last name again
barrett barrett barrett um
from what i understand you were killing
it in new york yeah you were kind of a
feminist
right
big feminist big feminist which we'll
talk about
uh but you transitioned from being a
kind of a boss babe into being a
housewife yeah so what have you learned
through that process well i also want to
say i was an entrepreneur i built two
businesses i sold the first one
um and i started the second one
actually failed during coven because it
relied on buildings we had contracts
that fell apart
investors that backed out things of that
nature
and so
through that whole process you know i
was living this boss babe life
you know um
just
yes for the majority of it i was single
um at the end i
i
met my husband at
an actual meeting so um
that was that
and we connected and we
never looked back we you know just fell
in love love at first sight
and um we started seeing each other
after that um but yeah i was a huge
feminist
a lot of that ideology is baked into our
society like through the media it's at a
very young age women are told yeah be
the boss babe you can do whatever you
want you have no consequences like just
keep doing that right
and then um
in marriage you find out
okay well there are roles that you have
to
in my opinion
that you have to play right and as a
wife
you know i learned i learned what that
was
during pre-marital counseling and then i
implemented that into my marriage and we
both work on it every day right so like
we live in modern society women work men
work all that stuff so you see an
example of this right 20 years together
20 years married different
style of relationship russon
different different for him right
and so
you you're seeing different dynamics
today but i i believe in traditional
values
so we had um ali drummond uh real femme
sapien on recently
who went viral for basically saying that
you know
this is how i got a husband by being a
feminine woman yeah and not you know
kind of playing into what society tells
women they need to be these days
so from your perspective
what should be the role of the modern
woman today yeah i mean the
the role of the modern wife i want to
say
is allowing your husband to lead
in the relationship um
and
taking
taking lead from him so i'm submissive i
know people don't like that word they
hate it the feminists come at me all
times
um but i'm submissive to my husband
meaning i'm not a doormat
i'm not a slave to my husband
i just follow his leadership and i
respect him and i respect
what he's done for my family for our
family and so
i
follow under that leader ali i believe
use the term willfully compliant yeah
wealthful cooperation cooperation would
you say that your husband leads you're
really i'm talking to you ali would you
say that your husband
leads your relationship and you follow
i might think we've always had a
partnership to be honest i mean i
definitely um i see the
i see what's happening with the the
roles in such a marriage and there's a
lot i'm actually probably more aligned
than you think is odd is that i live a
little bit differently um but i
i would say our we've always had a
partnership and let i i would say i look
to him overall for the
um safety of our family and security but
i think there's a lot that he looks to
me as well gotcha
do you lead your relationship with your
wife like she said so one of the common
phrases that we've learned in the
manosphere or the red pill community as
you say is that men lead women follow
sounds like that's something that you
abide by well yeah and you know i've
even learned this from
the church right the the man is the head
the woman's the neck you can't turn the
head without the neck ooh
so that's symbolism right there is that
something yeah
that's a great way to describe it yeah i
believe in complementarianism
um which is a view of everything right
so men and women are equal in value and
dignity and worth
however women have different roles men
have different roles and ideally
yeah the man is gonna lead he's gonna
provide but that doesn't mean that he's
a tyrannical yeah you know mobster
that's like
you know folks are getting whacked if
you don't know what i said and
oftentimes i think the best leaders in
any organizations are the people that
don't have to constantly remind you that
they're the leader they just lead and
because they're great leaders you follow
you know and so uh and and i do and my
wife is brilliant and she's very helpful
and i do listen to her so that's that's
not to say like you men don't never
listen to your wife yeah i do listen to
my wife there is a difference between a
leader and a boss yes correct you ever
seen that that picture of like yeah yeah
that little meme and the little meme
where like the leader is like follow me
and like the guys are behind him kind of
and he's leading whereas the boss is
behind them guy like whipping so if you
like that clip click right here to watch
another or if you want to watch the
entire sauce cast click right here
[Music]